♪ [Slow, orchestral music playing]
Cliff: All right. Well, good afternoon,
everyone.
We'd like to welcome you to
another Musicians@Google event.
I wanted to start off with a little
bit of bad news on this April 1st.
I know we have a lot of things
going on today
as you can see on the Google
home page
but I just did receive word
that the composer is dead.
So this might turn into a CSI@Google
instead of a Musicians@Google
but that's okay.
I'd like to introduce you to some of our
friends from the San Francisco Symphony.
In partnership with them we bring
you this presentation today
and it's really cool to see all of our young
and future Googlers in the audience as well.
So we hope you enjoy the speech.
It will primarily focus in our
discussion on music education
and young people's participation
in the symphony
which actually brings back a lot
of memories for me, as well.
I remember growing up
I was almost afraid of the performing
arts at the Crenet Center.
There was actually some unfortunate
incidents involving red balloons
and then I saw "Peter and the Wolf",
and I just --
I still feel sad about what
happened to the duck to this very day.
I think they get a very bad rap.
But fortunately the oboes
have a much happier fate
in this more recent book by Mr. Snicket.
So it's with great anticipation
that we bring this new book,
which, as you heard, is entitled
"The Composer is Dead",
that you learn a lot of the hidden back
story about what really happens
behind a symphony orchestra
and one thing I also noticed while
reading the book over the weekend
is that the violas do get off really,
really easily.
If you played in orchestra
you know what I mean.
So some minor things to
note for our curtain call.
A little bit of housekeeping.
Please use the mic for questions
and answers.
We'll actually have time for
some Q and A towards the end.
We also are streaming this live to
Googler's desktops worldwide
so be sure to speak into the mic
so they can hear your questions.
Also we are premiering
an interactive element
so if you all could go to
go/snicket at your leisure
that's also the place where you
can post some questions,
answer some of the survey elements
we're gonna introduce
into our talk today.
And just remember one thing
as you're reading the survey:
No one ever suspects the sousaphones.
So I'm very pleased to introduce
Ron Gallman,
who will tell us more about
today's program.
Thank you.
[Applause]
Ron: Thank you so much, Cliff,
and thanks to the entire
Google community
for hosting the San Francisco
Symphony again.
We're thrilled to be here.
I'd like to send a special shoutout
hello to all the kids out there.
Hi, guys.
The San Francisco Symphony is
very much committed to providing
programming of the highest quality,
of course, for adults through our program
-- through our subscription concerts
but also of course to children
through education programming.
We do that over the entire Bay
Area but here in the South Bay,
we present a special series of concerts
at Flint Center in Cupertino
and through the series of concerts
at the Flint center in Cupertino,
we're very, very much
committed to providing
the highest quality programming
both artistic and educationally
to our South Bay communities.
Google employees you should know
that you get a 50 percent off of --
of the price of those concerts at Flint.
There's more information about
that on the fliers that you have.
Well, today's program is a sneak peak
at one of the education concerts
that's coming up at Flint.
It's one of our music for families
concerts that takes place on April 4th,
that's this Saturday, 3:00 o'clock.
This is a program that is called
"The Composer is Dead".
It's a program that is based
on this wonderful,
wonderful original text
by Lemony Snicket,
incredible music by the composer
Nathaniel Stookey,
who's had a long history with
the San Francisco Symphony,
maybe Nathaniel will tell
us about that in a bit.
Nathaniel with a member of the San
Francisco Symphony Youth Orchestra
in his teens.
This performance of the words
and music
was commissioned by
the San Francisco Symphony.
The premier performances were
conducted by conductor Edwin Outwater,
and this mighty triumvirate is back
for us now to reprise that performance,
but on a very special occasion now that
HarperCollins has issued the book
"The Composer is Dead" along
with the CD with the music,
Lemony Snicket narrating,
Edwin Outwater conducting
the San Francisco Symphony.
So, this is a very special occasion for us
and we think it'll be a very special
occasion for all of you
Lemony Snicket fans out there.
I said this was a family concert.
The San Francisco Symphony
does a series of family concerts
both at Flint Center in Cupertino
and, also of course,
at Davies Symphony Hall
in San Francisco.
We do that because, uh,
presenting music to all ages,
to all constituencies,
is a part of what we do and what we
are as the San Francisco Symphony.
As the San Francisco Symphony,
of course,
we present concerts for adult audiences
at the highest levels of artistry
and at the same time we produce
education concerts,
concerts that engage young people,
families, parents, grandparents,
people of all ages.
And so you will see an example of that
at the music for families concert
on April 4th.
Well, without further ado,
I would like to introduce the group that
I refer to as our mighty triumvirate
and ask them to make their way up
to the magic chairs up front.
And so let's begin with, umm --
and, well, this is -- it is April Fool's day
but this is not an April Fool's,
I have to warn you.
Lemony Snicket, the very famous author,
as you know, umm, is very shy,
uh, is -- is prone to no-shows,
but we're all accustomed to that because
Mr. Snicket is almost always represented
by Mr. Daniel Handler,
the official representative.
[Applause]
Ron: The official representative
for Mr. Snicket in all matters,
umm, literary --
literary, matters of law,
and socially.
So we also have a live composer.
This is what they look like.
[Laughing]
Ron: Hello to Daniel Stookey,
our composer.
I report, Nathaniel Stookey,
our composer. For --
[laughing]
Ron: -- "The Composer is Dead".
And, of course,
any orchestra,
any orchestral work,
the San Francisco Symphony
needs a great leader
and the conductor of this project
is our very own conductor,
Edwin Outwater.
[Applause]
Ron: Hi, Edwin.
[Applause] Edwin: Hello.
Ron: Now, this is all you're
going to hear from me,
but before you actually hear from them,
we have a video clip for you.
Thank you.
Lemony: "The Composer is Dead".
♪ [Low brass music playing]
Lemony: "The Composer is Dead"
is a work for narrator and orchestra
that introduces the orchestra to people
who may otherwise be unfamiliar with it
or reintroduces the orchestra to
people who are familiar with it.
Nathaniel: We love classical music.
We hoped that people would
listen to this piece and think,
gosh, that's exciting.
I mean, this can do all these things that
I didn't think an orchestra could do.
♪ [Light orchestral music playing]
Lemony: Composer is a word which here
means a person who sits in a room,
muttering,
and humming,
and figuring out what notes is
the orchestra is going to play.
This is called "composing".
♪ [Light orchestral music playing]
Lemony: But last night the composer
was not muttering,
he was not humming,
he was not moving or even breathing.
[Light orchestral music playing]
Lemony: This is called
"decomposing."
[Laughing]
Lemony: It is a piece that
is designed to be performed
for narrator and orchestra
and then it also exists
as a recording
by the San Francisco Symphony,
it also exists as a book with the
recording tucked into the back.
And so I like to think of the --
the live performance of the piece
as kind of a butterfly,
and the recording as kind of a
pinning down of the butterfly.
Nathaniel: [Laughing]
Lemony: And then the book
is putting the pinned butterfly
in a small glass box
for people to stare at.
♪ [Brass music playing fanfare]
Lemony: The inspector was a very
handsome and intelligent person,
not unlike myself.
[Laughing]
Lemony: "The Composer is Dead"
begins with a composer,
who is dead.
His death is suspicious
and thus an inspector is called in
and the inspector knows
there are enemies of the composer
lurking in the orchestra
and so interrogates the orchestra
section by section.
Lemony: Perhaps the murderer
is lurking in the woodwinds.
Where were you last night,
woodwinds?
Speak up.
And each section of the orchestra
provides an alibi of varying credibility,
and also shows off a bit
in terms of its own range.
Lemony: "We were doing bird imitations",
said the flutes,
the shiniest and highest
pitched of the woodwinds.
It seems like that's all we ever do.
Whenever the orchestra needs a bird,
there we are.
♪ [Flute music playing lightly]
Lemony: Well, I like to think of
"The Composer is Dead"
as sort of a gateway drug.
Nathaniel: [Laughing]
Lemony: That will lead to a lifetime
addiction to classical music.
For me it was Beethoven's
third symphony, the Eroica,
that kind of broke it wide open.
You know, I couldn't stop
listening to it.
And it's like any other addiction.
Before I knew it I was listening to it alone,
I was listening to it in the morning,
and then slowly I went
from Beethoven to Bach,
I went from Bach to Mahler,
I went from Mahler to Shostakovich,
and see that's -- that's --
Nathaniel: That's addiction.
Lemony: -there's something wrong there.
And I hope that that wrong
will spread like a virus.
♪ [Music playing lightly]
Lemony: Oh. The violas.
I forgot all about you.
[Laughing]
Lemony: Everyone forgets about us.
Said the violas bitterly.
♪ [Violas playing slowly]
Lemony: We play the notes and
the chords that nobody cares about.
♪ [Violas playing slowly]
[Laughing]
Lemony: We play crucial
countermelodies nobody hears.
[Violas playing slowly]
Lemony: We often have to
stay late after performances
and stack up all of the chairs.
♪ [Violas playing slowly]
[Laughing]
Nathaniel: The music covers
quite a lot of territory
because I wanted people to get
the sense that the orchestra can do
just about anything.
There's a waltz,
there's a scene in a nightclub
that's basically techno,
then there's this incredibly
menacing music every time
he says the word "dead" which is this,
you know, growling --
Lemony: Thundering --
Nathaniel: - low brass.
Lemony: -- fanfare of doom that I wish
I could hear every time I said the word
"dead" just in everyday life.
[Low brass music playing]
[Applause]
Edwin: Hi, everybody.
I'm Edwin,
the conductor of this book and
concert coming up on Sunday
and I've been asked to kind
of interview these guys.
And we all kind of started this project --
I first I kind of --
I guess you guys both worked with
me before this project came out.
First Daniel did a "Peter and the Wolf"
with the San Francisco Symphony
which he re-wrote the words
to "Peter and the Wolf"
and it really became kind like
a no exit or stranger.
It's very, very depressing.
We got a few complaint letters from that.
And then we went on --
Daniel: You did? Really?
Edwin: Yeah. We did.
Daniel: Wow.
I'm sorry. My mother has
a lot of time on her hands.
[Laughing]
Edwin: So we knew we needed
to move forward and do more,
and Nathaniel, who was kind of from
the San Francisco Symphony family
had written this wonderful
piece that we performed
and then the idea came
up for this project to happen.
Uh, a new work to kind of introduce the
orchestra to audiences young and old
'cause there's still lots of people
who need to learn about the orchestra.
Daniel: In the hopes of wrecking --
breaking the record for complaints.
Edwin: Yeah. Exactly.
Daniel: We could outdo ourselves.
Edwin: And so we're gonna
talk a little bit today about
how it works and what makes
this project special.
Apparently, umm,
you can answer some questions
online Cliff mentioned to me
and these are the questions:
Who do you think killed the composer?
What instrument do you play?
And what instrument
would you like to play?
And we will give the results of that
towards the end of this presentation.
And I'm speaking for all of you --
Daniel: So you're encouraged
to only pay partial attention.
Edwin: Yeah.
[Laughing]
Edwin: And we're very --
Daniel: That's the Google way.
[Laughing]
[Applause]
Edwin: Speaking of which,
I've never been part of someone's
work life balance before
so it's really, really nice.
[Laughing]
Daniel: We're more a part of
the work life imbalance, I would think.
Edwin: Yeah. I suppose.
So this piece -- you know there have
been a lot of pieces that were written
for -- or some famous ones,
"Peter in the Wolf", by Prokofiev,
"The Young Person's Guide to the
Orchestra" by Benjamin Britten,
pieces which introduce
the different instruments,
the different sounds that
can be found in an orchestra.
In the case of "The Composer Is Dead"
rather than kind of going into the sounds
or what the instruments sound like,
like the oboe sounds like a duck,
you guys have decided
to kind of talk about
the stereotypes of an orchestra in a way,
like you guys heard in the
presentation that I'm sure
there's some sort of corporate
culture in Google,
some sort of Google in jokes that which
I may learn about by the end of the day
but in orchestra certainly
there are many jokes
and kind of stereotypes
of the instruments.
You may have noticed the violas
were referred to as kind of losers
of the orchestra.
And in fact if you go on,
for instance, viola.com
you will see a list of
hundreds and hundreds of viola jokes.
It's kind of a thing in the orchestra world.
One such joke is,
you know, you're driving a car,
you see a conductor
and a violist in the road.
Who do you run over first?
The answer is the conductor.
Business before pleasure.
So that's kind of this --
[Laughing]
Edwin: And it goes on and on.
So and the flutes are kind
of uptight and depressed,
even though they play happy
music all the time,
the brass players are arrogant jerks.
So what made you decide that angle?
What kind of brought you onto that?
Nathaniel: We got together in a
cafe in the Haight --
Daniel: Yes.
Nathaniel: Basically because
I'd played in an orchestra,
I gave Daniel everything that I knew,
Daniel's also a musician so knew a fair
number of these things beforehand
but I think for instance,
the composer decomposing is
an old orchestra joke umm,
and, uh, the viola stereotype
is certainly the --
that's the pillar of orchestra
lore in a way.
Daniel: Yeah. I grew up as a boy soprano
in the San Francisco boy's chorus,
umm, I've played three seasons of
Amahl in Amhal and the Night Visitors
in the Oakland Opera.
I have my clippings with me if
people would like to see them after.
Daniel: And, umm,
and then puberty came along
and wrecked my career.
And it had never really occurred to
me when I was a boy soprano that
it could go downhill so quickly.
Unlike playing just about any other
instrument you can keep it going.
You can't actually --
once if you're a man
and you develop your secondary
sex characteristics
that's the end of your career
as a soprano.
Nathaniel: I'm sorry.
Daniel: My parents say that
they considered castration
to keep my career going.
[Laughing]
But they didn't do it.
Daniel: Umm, and so I think I funneled
some of that bitterness and jealousy
towards people who do anything else
but sing in the world of classical music
to exploit the stereotypes
while working on this piece.
And, umm,
the piece has been performed
all over the place.
Umm, I have stepped in for
Lemony Snicket performing it
on a number of occasions
and every time that I have
at least one person in the orchestra
has told me that they're offended.
So in that way --
Nathaniel: Especially the concert
masters. It gives them a very bad rap.
Daniel: Well, yeah.
There's always someone
who's offended.
Umm, the text of the piece says
that there are two kinds of violins,
there are the first violins who
have the trickier parts to play
and the second violins who are
more fun at parties. [Laughing]
Daniel: Umm,
and a second violinist came
up to me and said that uh,
she just wanted me to know
that that wasn't true. [Laughing]
Daniel: That it was only that
the first violins had the higher parts
and the second violins
had slightly lower parts.
And I said that don't worry.
No one would ever think she
was more fun at parties.
[Laughing]
Daniel: And that didn't really resolve
the conflict, surprisingly. [Laughing]
Daniel: Umm,
but there've been various complaints
with each orchestra so, umm,
I like to think that that's the piece --
Nathaniel: It's thinning out.
Daniel: Yeah.
Edwin: I think, uh,
the words definitely kind of cover it.
It's really like an insider's
look into orchestra life.
'Cause orchestras are interesting things.
I mean when we're in orchestra,
as an orchestra musician people ask us
to this day is this a full-time job?
You know, what do you do?
Do you sell frozen yogurt
after the rehearsal?
And, uh, of course,
an orchestra like the San Francisco
Symphony is --
is a group of musicians
who are like athletes, you know,
there's incredibly difficult auditions
to get into the orchestra they play
a different concert every
single week, umm --
Nathaniel: Or more than one.
Edwin: Yeah, or more than one,
like this Daniel Snicket project.
In fact, this week there are two
separate orchestras going on
at the San Francisco Symphony.
There's -- I think they're splitting two --
and so this book kind of -- more than the
other book kind of gets into that world.
And I want to talk a little bit about
the music, Nat, because, umm,
when you came in here there was this
beautiful background music going on,
you know, to get you nice and relaxed,
which happened to be Beethoven
and Brahms, and Mozart
and I wonder what they would
have thought of that,
you know, to have their music
be background music at Google.
The conductor --
Nathaniel: Or in a book.
Edwin: Or in a book.
Yeah. The conductor, Daniel Barenboim
kind of left the country
because he was so offended by hearing
classical music as background music
'cause obviously it's very far kind of from
where it was first intended to be written.
And your music, uh,
it's not background music, I think.
So how did you use the music --
did you start with the words
or did you write the music
around the words?
Nathaniel: Yeah, definitely.
We talked at first and then
Daniel sent me a draft,
which I butchered.
Umm,
and the good thing is since Daniel
had -- was an opera fan he had --
he was kind of expecting
his words to be butchered
so that the music could be pasted --
Daniel: And also 'cause I've
known you for a long time.
Nathaniel: [Laughing]
Daniel: Umm, Nathaniel and
I went to high school together
and then didn't keep in touch, umm,
and now I think both of us
kind of understand --
Nathaniel: Understand why.
Daniel: -- wish it had gone on that way.
[Laughing]
Daniel: But so he was
presented with a draft of the text --
Daniel: -- and then he would
invite me over to his house.
It is.
Yes, it's awful.
[Laughing]
Daniel: I would get
upset about it if I thought about it.
And, uh, then he would invite
me over to his house
and he would prepare strange meals
from odd-ball vegetables
found at local markets
and, umm,
and then he would say --
he would play me a bit of a piece,
sometimes on a piano,
sometimes on a very bad software
he used to mimic the sound
of an orchestra.
Terrible, probably made by Yahoo!
if you know what I'm saying.
[Laughing]
Daniel: And, umm,
then, uh,
he would say, you see now how we have
to -- the words need to be changed.
And I would say,
not a single syllable, you cur.
And you have to change every
single note in this piece.
You've gotten it all wrong.
And he would say, not a single note.
I'm the genius here.
And then we would have, uh,
some, umm, beer. [Laughing]
Daniel: I can say that
in front of young people; right?
You shouldn't have any but --
[Laughing]
Daniel: -- it's okay for me
to have as much as I want.
Umm, and then I would say
all right just a few words.
And he would say okay
just a few notes.
And from that the collaboration
was hammered down.
Hammered down.
With the emphasis on the word
"hammered" I guess [Laughing]
Edwin: And your music, Nat, I mean,
when you were writing the music,
were you thinking of kids,
were you thinking of adults?
Like, were you thinking of --
Nathaniel: I was thinking most of
all of the players in the orchestra
'cause I wanted it to be fun for them.
There's a lot of crappy children's
music that they have to play
and I wanted this to be something
that they could sink their teeth into.
You know, the jokes are kind
of inside jokes for them.
And I actually wrote to the principals
of the symphony
and got in trouble for doing
that but some of them --
some of the players wrote back to me.
Like, the tuba player
who has a great solo in this piece,
umm, wrote me back and said,
sure, I'll meet with you.
So we met and I said,
what do you most want to play?
What would you really love to
play that you never get to play?
And I said --
Daniel: And he said the guitar. [Laughing]
Daniel: Sorry, I just --
Nathaniel: Just like the poll
that we're asking you to do.
Which instrument do you wanna play?
He said -- so, anyway,
that's --
I really wrote it first
for the players, umm,
second probably for people of our
generation who never go to the symphony.
Edwin: Which generation are we?
Nathaniel: I don't know.
Whichever --
Daniel: We're very young.
Nathaniel: We're the youngest people here.
Umm, and then probably lastly
for my kids' generation,
who are important, too,
but I was actually thinking
most of the friends of mine
who never go to the symphony first
and then hopefully they bring
their kids as well.
Edwin: And so how -- you're writing for
people who don't go to the symphony
what does that mean in are you --
are you writing music that
they've heard before
and kind of integrating to lure them in,
or are you writing something
you just think they'll like, or --
Nathaniel: I guess I wasn't
that calculating.
I mean, it was really more, uh,
fun for me.
You know, I started from the words
which are fun to begin with and I
wanted to write music that was fun.
But yeah it does cover
kind of a wide range
from about like this interview earlier
interview says techno and waltz.
There's a lot of dance music.
Edwin: So what are your techno influences?
Nathaniel: Uh, you'd have to --
I don't know what my influences are.
Daniel knows a lot more about my
influences probably than I do.
Edwin: What are Nat's influences?
What are my techno influences?
Daniel: Just 'cause I read his diary.
Derek May. I don't know.
Daniel: I guess the idea in incorporating
different styles was to
become less lonely, frankly,
because, umm, when you're
interested in classical music,
as the three of us are,
people look at you funny.
You know, so if you go and
you're sitting with friends
and you all might talk about things
that you've read in a magazine,
and everyone's on the same page,
and then you might talk about television,
and everyone's talking about that, too,
and then you might talk about pop music
and everyone's kinda friendly
and if someone says
yeah, it actually reminds me of the
Shostakovich quartet there at the end.
Slowly everyone --
there's a -- you can -- there's a tangible
feeling that changes in the room.
Nathaniel: I hate that.
Daniel: And, umm,
it's a terrible feeling,
it's very very lonely.
Nathaniel: Alienating.
Daniel: Yeah. Yes. It's --
if there were a campus, say,
for classical music lovers
it would be a lot smaller
and the food would be
a lot worse -- [Laughing]
Daniel: -- than the campus
that we're on now.
And so I just thought that
if I seduced more people
into the world of classical music
then maybe I wouldn't be as lonely
and wretched as I am now. [Laughing]
Edwin: So. Yeah.
It's kind of sad.
I did kinda the same background.
I mean, for me I was,
I came into classical music later,
uh, I was kind of a rock kid.
My dad worked for a record company
and my first concert was Alice Cooper
or something because -- you still --
Daniel: For those that don't know
who she is --
Edwin: She's a fantastic --
[Laughing]
Daniel: Wonderful soprano.
Daniel: [Singing in high-piched voice]
♪ School's out for summer.
No.
[Laughing]
Edwin: But I think we got pulled in,
you know, at one point.
I mean, did you hear --
did you hear classical -- see,
Daniel also works a lot
with rock musicians,
you write about rock music sometimes.
He was at one point working on
a compilation of 80s sync pop,
you know, for Rhino Records
which may or may not come out.
You play with the "Magnetic Fields",
"Steven Merit",
so did you come to rock first or
did you come to classical first?
Daniel: No, I came to
classical music first.
I only listen to classical music.
And in fact it was my friend,
David Fisher, in sixth grade,
umm, who I'm sure you all know.
Uh, he said to me --
he gave me an album by
"Men at Work" and he said --
-- you have to start listening to pop
music or no one's going to like you.
That's the kind of loneliness and
desolation that I'm talking about.
I'm not sure actually that in the long
run my deep love for Shostakovich
which has served me not as well as
listening to the "Men at Work" album.
I'm not sure actually listening to
"Men at Work" that makes me any cooler
I didn't hear any popular music at all
until I was --
until I was entering teenagerdom.
Edwin: Hmm.
Daniel: Which is also to be
said about background music.
There was less of it.
Nowadays you cannot --
sometimes I'll read about a --
a hit song and I think
I won't have heard it
and I'll hear it and realize
I've heard it a thousand times
because there's so many
opportunities to hear music.
But when I was growing up there
wasn't as much music constantly
in the air all the time.
And so I only listened to classical
music and then came into pop.
Edwin: Yeah.
Daniel: There's still big swaths
of pop music I'm ignorant of
'cause my parents didn't listen to it.
Neil Diamond, Barbara Streisand,
I don't know --
I couldn't name -- yeah.
Led Zeppelin.
Nathaniel: Britney.
Daniel: Britney.
Nathaniel: Only I listen to Britney.
Daniel: No. I wouldn't --
Edwin: You have the weirdest musical
taste of anyone I've ever met, Nat.
I mean, 'cause you actually don't listen
to a lot of music which is kind of cool.
I mean --
I.
Nathaniel: In a way.
Edwin: In a way.
No because like I think Daniel
and I are more similar
because we'll go to Amoeba Records
and, oh, have you heard this? Or this?
Nathaniel: Cultural consumers.
Edwin: Consuming stuff.
Whereas you actually consume very
little music as kinda it comes in.
You're much more kind of creating --
Nathaniel: The only time I hear
music is at dance clubs.
That's why I'm familiar with the work --
Edwin: Yeah.
Nathaniel: -- of Miss Spears.
[Laughing]
Nathaniel: -- or at concert halls.
So,
yeah, I don't listen to
a lot of recorded music.
Edwin: So you're obsessed for
instance with the Umbrella Song,
Rihanna --
Nathaniel: Yeah. It's fantastic.
Edwin: And did that make its way,
some of this Britney and Rihanna,
into your --
Nathaniel: I don't know. Well, you asked
earlier about my influences
and I don't -- wouldn't say that I have
specific influences in that --
I mean, the fact that I don't listen
to recorded music means
I most often I don't know
what I'm listening to
'cause I can't pick up the CD
or look on iTunes and what it is.
It's just kind of all in the mix.
If I'm at a club, umm,
you know, there are all these
things are kind of drifting around.
Uh,
so no.
Not in any specific way.
Edwin: Mm hmm.
So --
Daniel: Do you want me to get
your questions that you dropped?
Edwin: No. That's just my rundown.
Daniel: All right.
Edwin: So what would you like to --
Daniel: I felt bad for you when it dropped.
I thought, there we go.
Edwin: I've heard that --
Daniel: It's all over.
Edwin: I know.
Anyway.
I just learned --
can I say this?
Can I talk about like what
might happen with this book?
Daniel: Sure.
Edwin: You have --
you have all these ideas, like,
one of which there's gonna be a puppet
show of this piece coming up at some point.
Daniel: I am. I'm working
with some puppeteers,
umm, because the goal of the piece
was to bring this music to a lot of people
and one of the stumbling blocks
that I didn't anticipate
was that there are so many places
where it's really not --
they don't have a symphony orchestra
and it's not feasible to bring
a symphony orchestra there.
Umm,
and that was a source
of frustration for me
because when I go and talk
about the Lemony Snicket books
I go all over the place.
I go to towns that don't
have bookstores or libraries,
and as well as big cities,
and suburbia,
and all these places,
so I thought, well, how hard can it be to
bring a whole symphony orchestra with you?
As it turns out kinda hard.
So, umm --
Edwin: Well, also you know, sorry.
The piece itself is not easy to play and --
Daniel: Right.
Edwin: -- in fact it takes more time --
it's actually quite difficult to pull off.
Daniel: And people kept saying,
couldn't you just bring a piano player?
And I said, well, it's hard to play a piece
that introduces the orchestra
instrument by instrument -
Edwin: [Laughing]
Daniel: -- and only have one instrument.
Nathaniel: As much as we'd love to do.
Daniel: Yeah. Umm...
Edwin: [Laughing]
Daniel: Umm, I said it in a more
incredulous tone of voice
the first time they asked me.
Umm, and so, uh,
we had this recording
and I had an idea that
we had the recording so we can bring it.
And so at first I thought, well,
you can have an orchestra
kind of lip syncing or not --
or bow sinking and air violining fingering--
Edwin: Like the inauguration.
Daniel: That didn't seem --
Edwin: [Humming]
Daniel: That didn't seem feasible either
and then I met these puppeteers
and actually can make him communicate
through the world of music
called Phantom Limb --
I'm sure people are looking it up
right now online --
uh, Phantom Limb and, umm,
the -- it's a married couple
who makes these puppets
and the husband used to be the bass
player in The Lounge Lizards
which was a band I liked a lot.
Erik Sanko.
Glad to see someone's representative
for the Lounge Lizards here.
And, umm,
and so they're making puppets
and I hope that will bring the puppet
show everywhere.
They're really, really
awesome-looking puppets.
Edwin: That could be lonelier than being
a classical musician, talking to puppets.
Daniel: That's actually what was
nice about talking to puppeteers is
when I've told them about my loneliness
there was a pause and then,
he explained to me that he used to be
the bass player for this punk jazz band
and he'd now moved into
the world of puppets.
So I'd actually found a little
lonelier soul than I.
[Laughing]
Edwin: Well, I'd like to --
Daniel: So I hardly ever call him.
[Laughing]
Daniel: 'Cause I'm the popular
crowd compared to him.
Edwin: I wanna talk about
one specific part of this piece
'cause we're coming to the end
of this interview segment,
even though I dropped my sheet
of paper I do remember that.
And it's the kind of grand finale of
this piece, Nat, that you composed,
in which I think, you're going to
kind of perform in just a little bit.
And it's kind of the funeral march.
Of course, as you might imagine,
the end of this piece
involves a funeral march.
Umm, and kind of a listing of
all the composers who are dead.
Because another thing
about being classical --
a classical musician is -- you're
working mostly with dead artists
and you're trying to figure
out what they were --
what they meant when they
wrote it 'cause they didn't --
you know, there were
no recordings of
Brahms or some maybe one or two
recordings of his friend Ruakey
who played his violin concerto.
But anyway, umm,
and what you did was really extraordinary.
You took --
as each composer is named off,
you took an excerpt of his music--
they're all male in this case --
and --
and kinda put a mosaic of music together
out of their pieces in their original key.
Now that's difficult, actually,
because, umm,
these pieces are all in different keys
so to make it all come together
as exact quotes is kind of incredibly
difficult puzzle to solve,
umm, which is what you're gonna hear.
So every time you hear the composer's
name you'll hear his music played.
And what was that like doing that?
I mean, that just seems
unbelievably tricky.
Nathaniel: It was by far
the hardest part to write
even though I didn't write any of it.
Umm... [Laughing]
Nathaniel: Because I really wanted -
even though this is a silly piece
I wanted these --
I wanted this to be a tribute to these
composers and also to the players
who are used to playing these things.
You know, they have this music in their
fingers and you don't want it transposed.
They want it where it --
where it belongs.
And so it was a huge puzzle trying to figure
out how to put it together and get it to flow.
There were 13 excerpts.
Umm, but the good thing about it
from my point of view is that
I can listen to it in this way and then
when you put Daniel's words on top of it,
it suddenly becomes this hilarious thing
and somehow it-- you know, those two -
those two poles don't detract for me.
Umm, I think one of the great
things about --
about music is that it has this potential
to express wildly different things
and though people may think of
classical music of being stodgy,
or having a particular sort of
mood about it can really --
you have this huge palette and you can
do pretty much whatever you want with it.
Daniel: Well, I've always thought that
horror and hilarity were more or
less the same thing and, umm,
it's true that towards the end
of The Composer is Dead, umm,
it becomes clear that the composer's
death is pat of a conspiracy
and that practically every composer
you've heard of is dead.
And, umm,
and so when I pointed that
out to Nathaniel
he began to start working on this,
umm, funeral march
that is this kind of mash up
of different excerpts
that are all by the composers named
and are all pieces about death.
And I was really worrying for him
when he was working on it
because previously he'd been fairly calm.
He had a piano where he
kind of tries out a few things
and then this software that helps him
write all the -- keep all the parts straight
but other than that he's
just kind of muttering
and humming to himself like we all do.
And -- or -- the two of us do, anyway.
Nathaniel: [Laughing]
Daniel: And then when he started
working on this I would go and visit him
and he had borrowed all
these scores from libraries,
and friends, and things,
that were all spread out all over the place
and he was kind of trying to combine
them all into this thing and I --
I realized that I had
suggested the idea
that it was a conspiracy
of dead composers
and that this idea was gonna
engulf him and kill him.
Umm, but he did -- he did survive so far,
knock on plastic. [Laughing]
Daniel: But what -- it was fascinating
to see that he was trying to work
all of these other composers
in there together.
It was a scary thing.
It was kind of like, umm,
you know, when you might
have a suspicious tenant
and then you go in to visit
his apartment just to check
and he has a bunch of pictures
of the President or something.
It had that kind of creepy
feeling about it
that he had all these scores
of dead composers
and that he was working on
this piece about death.
And --
Nathaniel: Bad karma.
Daniel: And in some way it was a triumph
because how I knew him in high school is
that he was tall and blond
and fluent in French
and he could have any girl
that he wanted.
So ... [Laughing]
Nathaniel: So you saw me reduced
to this kind of --
Nathaniel: Serial killer, fangs.
Daniel: It was kind of satisfying.
Nathaniel: -- putting up push pins
in the map.
Daniel: Yeah. And then our
reunion was coming up,
meanwhile, so I was confident
he would be a trembling figure.
But he's recuperated,
more or less.
Umm, so now --
Edwin: I think --
Daniel: I'll perform that part.
As you can see,
there's no orchestra here
so we're using the recording,
but I'll play the part of the narrator
and you'll play the part of the audience.
Edwin: Did we ever practice this?
Daniel: No. I've never done
this before in my life.
♪ [Slow orchestral music playing]
Daniel: Oh. There it went.
Start it over, please.
♪ [Slow orchestral music playing]
Daniel: Beethoven.
Dead.
♪ [Slow orchestral music playing]
Daniel: Bach.
Edwin: Bach?
Daniel: Dead.
Daniel: Brahms.
♪ [Slow orchestral music playing]
Daniel: Dead.
Daniel: Mozart.
♪ [Slow orchestral music playing]
Daniel: Dead.
Daniel: Haydn.
Dead.
Daniel: Schubert,
unfinished but dead.
Daniel: Mahler.
♪ [Slow orchestral music playing]
Daniel: Mahler!
Daniel: Dead.
Daniel: Chopin.
Romantic.
♪ [Slow orchestral music playing]
Daniel: Dead.
Daniel: Tchaikovsky.
Dramatic!
♪ [Slow orchestral music playing]
Daniel: Dead.
Daniel: Stravinsky.
Ecstatic!
♪ [Slow orchestral music playing]
Daniel: Dead.
Schoenberg.
Incomprehensible.
But dead.
♪ [Slow orchestral music playing]
Daniel: Berlioz, dead.
Purcell, dead.
Prokofiev, dead.
Vivaldi, dead.
Sibelius, Ives,
Handel,
Britten,
Mendelssohn,
Scriabin,
Liszt,
Messien,
Copland,
Cage,
Dvorak,
Shostakovich,
Vigini,
Rossini,
Porcini,
Bellini,
J.C. Bach,
W.F. Bach,
C.P.E. Bach,
Offenbach,
Horari!
Dead composers litter
the musical world
and it's all because of one man,
the murderer himself.
Arrest him at once.
♪ [Brass fanfare playing]
[Woodwinds imitating ambulance]
♪ [Orchestral music playing]
Daniel: "Not so fast",
said the entire orchestra in unison.
The murderer didn't work alone.
♪ [Slow orchestral music playing]
Daniel: All of us have butchered a
composer at one time or another.
♪ [Slow orchestral music playing]
Daniel: But we also keep
composers alive.
♪ [Slow orchestral music playing]
Daniel: Without strings,
and woodwinds,
without brass and percussion,
there would be no composing at all.
♪ [Slow orchestral music playing]
Daniel: Except for various kinds
of non orchestral music.
[Bell chiming]
Daniel: If you want to hear the work
of the world's greatest composers,
you're going to have to allow for
a little murder here and there.
♪ [Slow, low orchestral music playing]
Daniel: But that's injustice.
Those who want justice,
said the orchestra,
can go to the police.
But those who want something a little
more interesting than justice...
Should go...
To the orchestra.
♪ [Brisk orchestral music playing]
[Applause]
Edwin: That was great.
Daniel: That was very strange
to do it without an orchestra.
It was quite strange.
That's why I made some textural --
Edwin: Yeah, I noticed that.
Daniel: -- changes so as not to, umm,
give away the end of the episode of
"Murder She Wrote" before we reached it.
Edwin: Well, it's even better live
and it's what, this Saturday at three --
Daniel: At the Flint Center --
Edwin: -- so we invite you all to come.
Daniel: -- named after the device
used to make fire.
[Laughing]
Edwin: That's where technology started,
right? At the Flint Center.
Daniel: Yeah. That's right.
Nathaniel: And a lovely town in Michigan.
Daniel: And its end point is Google.
[Laughing]
Daniel: It started with fire,
and you're the end.
Edwin: That's very morbid.
Umm, so,
do we have our poll results,
speaking of technology? Yeah.
Daniel: This just in.
Cliff: So, now, if you want to vote
as I am reading the results
this is a live questioning of Google
moderator at go/snicket.
Umm, the first question shall we do the --
we'll start out with the easy one.
Did you play an instrument growing up?
The clear winner is the piano.
It seems to be the popular thing,
though harder to carry these days.
Edwin: What are the next ones?
Cliff: And then we had guitar,
and then my personal favorite, the cello.
Edwin: That was three?
Cliff: That was three.
Edwin: I had a violin.
For those of you who have kids,
don't teach them the violin.
Teach them the bassoon.
Or the base clarinet,
or the trom -- we need those.
We need those in orchestra.
I used to run a youth orchestra --
Daniel: I you had children
you'd feel differently.
Edwin: I don't know.
'Cause we have all these kids lining up
to audition to do something
and they all play violin.
Bassoon.
Viola. Sorry.
They might get beaten up that way.
Daniel: Comb and tissue paper.
Cliff: So -- or the musical saw
as in one of the productions I've seen.
And then we have the saxophone
rounding out the folks
that didn't play an instrument,
or played the flute.
So on the other hand the --
Daniel: Wait. People who didn't play an
instrument played the saxophone?
Cliff: Well, it -- it depends on what
you were listening to but yeah.
There were more saxophone players than
folks that did not play an instrument.
Daniel: Oh.
Edwin: It's the Lisa Simpson
influence, I think.
Cliff: Basically. Yeah.
Umm, and then --
Daniel: or John Coltrane.
Cliff: In terms of the instruments
of people's dreams once again
my personal favorite, although the
bassoon was a close -- not on the list.
The cello rounded out first,
we had the piano and drums,
followed by one of the more difficult
instruments in the orchestra,
which is the air guitar,
umm, violin beating out the pipe organ.
Daniel: Hmm.
Cliff: So.
Daniel: In real life the violin
could never beat out the pipe organ.
Cliff: Just by force of shear numbers
it's just not gonna happen.
Daniel: It would be --
it's the pipes really. You know.
Cliff: The pipes will do you in.
Daniel: Yep.
Cliff: And then finally the question
of who done
it is voted by the results
of Google moderator
through Google offices worldwide
start to place the first finger
there actually is a tie
so two fingers going at
two different murderers.
The first one being Mr. Lemony Snicket.
Daniel: Hmm.
Cliff: What can I say?
Daniel: I'll pass that along.
Cliff: Yes. We'll try to find him
after the show.
Umm, and then also the sousaphones
like I said in my intro,
no one suspects the sousaphones,
then the violas and the audience rounding
out some sort of co-conspiracy bit.
Daniel: Wow!
Cliff: So those are our questions.
We also have time for some
Q and A from the audience
and also for our remote offices you can
put your questions in on go/snicket.
Thank you.
Daniel: This part's awkward.
[Laughing]
Daniel: you don't have to ask questions.
Nathaniel: Alternatively.
Daniel: Yeah. That's the great thing
about America.
Nathaniel: We can get some
free cookies.
Daniel: We went and did this
in Saudi Arabia
and everyone had to ask questions
but here in America --
-- you don't have to.
Nathaniel: Yeah. Question?
>> Read one from the, uh --
Daniel: Sure. I think you have to read it
into the microphone for, umm --
Nathaniel: Posterity.
Daniel: Posterity, yeah.
We wouldn't wanna lose this.
[Laughing]
>> Well, I don't have any questions
of my own but somebody asked,
are there any plans to
extend the performance dates?
Daniel: Umm,
well, not extend the performance dates in
that we can't camp out at the Flint Center
and see if more people are up for it.
But, umm,
the piece has been performed all
over the place, all over America,
and I -- it was the most performed
piece of new music last year
which is a little bit like being
the world's tallest midget --
-- but it's still --
[Laughing]
Nathaniel: And it appeared
in German last season.
It also appeared in Australian.
Daniel: Yes.
So, umm --
[Laughing]
Daniel: You should, if you live on earth,
umm, it will be more or less
convenient to go see it.
I mean,
like, where you live on earth.
Edwin: It's not like a Broadway runner.
You kinda have to wait and --
Daniel: Yeah.
Edwin: It's come back.
>> Could you say a little more about
the difficulty of performing this?
I just -- this subject just came up, umm,
as a new Naxos recording
of some wind band music
and the composer was talking about
why he was so pleased to do --
to compose for a wind band
because you could get their attention
to actually rehearse a really
complicated piece
and orchestras only get to like play
something three times and, you know.
Edwin: Oh, Yeah. Well,
a lot of -- you know,
since we're doing a different concert
every week at the San Francisco ,
we have a limited amount
of time to prepare it.
And sometimes, umm, I mean,
the orchestras are such virtuosos
they can often play things very quickly in
one rehearsal of a Beethoven symphony,
or even in a read through
of a Beethoven symphony,
umm, with San Francisco I would say
70 percent of our audience
couldn't tell the difference of,
you know, what we actually work on.
It's kind of like this higher stuff,
to ultra refine things 'cause
the players are so great.
When it's a new piece it
takes a little bit more time.
So what made it challenging is that,
umm, there's no collective memory of the
piece for the orchestra when we play it,
though we did it this time,
we had done it three years ago
and they remembered
a great deal of the piece even though
they've played 40, you know,
hundreds and hundreds of pieces
in between
which is kind of what's so amazing
about an orchestra.
And I find usually the more complex
the music is as far as writing,
the more hard it is to play sometimes.
I mean, this idea of Nat's to combine
this kind of mosaic of composers
was sort of the hardest part to rehearse.
Umm, the Right of Spring Stravinsky
excerpt is often done in different meters.
We had to do it -- it was notated
differently so the players were, like,
seeing this kinda piece turned
upside down in front of them.
They got -- actually,
some of them screamed
playing the Right of Spring in four
'cause it was usually in
one, two one, two, three.
So, umm, but it's a thrill and that's
what makes orchestras --
orchestral music I think has
a level of complexity,
uh, that, you know,
I could objectively say,
you know, having written and
listened to all sorts of music,
and having loved all sorts of
music has a level of complexity,
umm, that other kinds of music don't
have as far as how they're put together.
Now, jazz can be incredibly complex
if it needs be or a rock --
a great guitar solo but there's something
about the notes being written down
and combined on the page, uh,
from Bach's playing way back there's
that connection between that mad mix
in music that makes classical music
particularly challenging I think.
Daniel: And I think also, umm,
because it's a piece for children
that some orchestras think,
oh, well, how complicated can it be?
Which reminds me -
Nathaniel:--and they tend to pigeon hole.
Daniel: Yeah.
So then we get there and they say,
oh, gosh. It's actually really hard.
It actually remind me a little bit of,
umm, having children.
[Laughing]
Daniel: You think, well,
you need a little bed, right?
And then you're kinda done.
[Laughing]
Daniel: Umm, and it turns out,
you know--
Daniel: Just to --
I mean, my son's five now and
he's still shaky on the difference
between sweet and dry vermouth.
It's -- [Laughing]
Daniel: I don't know how many times
I have to go over it with him. [Laughing]
Nathaniel: Did you have
another question?
>> Let's see. I'll start off
with a word of warning.
I've never encountered a puppet
orchestra that can handle
anything written in A sharp,
so, you know.
Daniel: Good to know.
>> Second, as a former tuba player,
I thank you for, you know,
of corresponding with them and
they're very rarely heard from.
My question was, umm,
there's a sort of tradition of combining
humor and music with people
like Anna Russel and Peter Schickele
and I was wondering
if you drew on them at all,
if you're familiar with them.
Nathaniel: I didn't really.
As Edwin said earlier I'm not --
I spend all day writing music
so I don't really have a lot
left to listen to music.
Umm, I did, uh,
meet Peter Schickele when I was working
with the North Carolina Symphony
and I admire what he does
but I couldn't say that
I really know what
he does enough to have --
to be influenced by it familiarly.
What really guided me
were Daniel's words.
Edwin: Would you find that humor makes
its way into your music generally
or is this an exception?
Nathaniel: Well, I guess it maybe
has more but I do think that
music can express anything
and that we, umm --
you know, the idea that music --
classical music especially --
has to be serious, and highbrow,
and high-minded all the time
I think is -- is limiting it.
So yeah, I mean, I think a lot of my music
has little sections that are quirky
and then sections that, for me,
at least, writing them are moving.
I mean I wouldn't say that I was really
looking at people who do one kinda thing.
I mean, if anything, my model
would be Mozart. You know.
Daniel: He's good.
Nathaniel: He's good.
Edwin: Also funny.
Daniel: Yeah.
Nathaniel: And -- and -- that's
what I mean. That's what I mean.
That he had a sense of humor,
you know, it wasn't, just like this is
fun music or this is kids music,
this is grown up music,
this is serious music,
this is new music which
means it's one kind of way.
I mean, I wanted it to be just,
you know, bigger, rounder.
Daniel: That's one of the admirable
things about Nathaniel Stookey's music
is that it crosses a lot of boundaries.
In fact, the first commission that
he received after this commission
from the San Francisco Symphony --
-- was to become the first composer
in residence
at the San Francisco City dump.
[Laughing]
Nathaniel: Yeah. So you can go listen to
junkestra which is somewhere online at
that sunset scavenger and it's a very,
you know, very different thing
'cause it's a very different breed.
Edwin: It's all instruments
made of junk, by the way.
>> So, my son was pretty into classical
music when he was, like, three, four, five.
Umm, I guess it was just very visceral
and he enjoyed that part of it.
But now at seven, eight,
it's got no lyrics so he's
not interested in it.
It's boring.
Edwin: You tried to raise him right.
>> So the answer -- you know,
obvious answer is,
well, opera.
But you know,
that has its issues.
Umm, most of which is that it's not in
English and he can't understand any of it.
So, umm, can you throw out
any pieces with actual,
you know, narration or opera
in English that might be,
you know, appealing or
interesting to this --
the same age group
that this appeals to?
Daniel: A piece with narrator and
orchestra.
Edwin: I don't --I think you're kinda tapping
into a bigger subject with kids and music.
I think if my dad gave me anything
to listen to I would be, like, no,
when I was a little kid.
In fact, when -- when I was -- my parents
tried to play classical music for me
when I was young and
I would turn off the radio.
I wouldn't listen to it just
because of the way in which
it was being transmitted
to me as a kid.
And I found myself coming
back to it at around 14.
I -- just through my friends,
and through playing music in
the schools and it kind of, uh,
kind of took me.
But I think if my parents hadn't played
it for me when I was younger
that maybe wouldn't have primed me
to accept it later on in life, you know.
And, umm,
I think the visceral comment
is also interesting
because there's this weird culture that's
evolved around classical music that, umm,
that it's not visceral, umm,
which is actually not --
the composers are being
shocked to know that.
Because what's more visceral
than a hundred people, like,
playing together in a live -- in
a live kind of situation in umm,
compared to rock 'n' roll
I know what you mean.
There's not a beat or this or that.
But one -- I think all three of our missions
in life is that the music actually has
fundamentally visceral qualities and fun
qualities but the culture around the music,
umm, like this kind of --
the stilted background music
we heard as we walked in,
or this kind of atmosphere that
has developed in the concert hall
over the years that has to do with
kind of Edith Wharton novels, you know,
this dressy, where you clap in
between movements.
Daniel: Which I would also
add or grossly misinterpret.
People are poisoning each other in
Edith Wharton novels all the time.
[Laughing]
Edwin: But I -- it's kind of a mission,
you know?
Daniel: They are. You know? When
people think Edith Wharton novel,
they think, oh, lord Worthington,
when actually it's this
back stabbing murder.
It's great.
Edwin: Yeah. But there's this culture
that grows up around art
that makes it untouchable.
People who are really fans of it
treat it and put it up on a pedestal.
You're not supposed to
clap in between movements.
Someone told me that once.
I was conducting a Mozart concert
and someone, this woman said,
what do you think about people clapping
in between the Mozart symphony?
I said, well, you know, I liked it,
and Mozart actually liked it, too,
'cause when Mozart's time people not
only clapped in between movements,
they encored the movements.
They would clap until
you had to play it again.
And that's totally vanished
and I would much rather hear
applause in between movements
than candy wrappers and coughing
which is the thing that's developed
in place of that.
I think it's absolutely bizarre, you know.
But for kids I love Right of Spring, man.
That's my piece.
Daniel: That's true.
That's true.
Nathaniel: I wouldn't go with the lyrics.
Edwin: No lyrics yet.
Nathaniel: Because if you try
to find something with lyrics
it's just not gonna satisfy them
'cause they're not gonna be lyrics
they're gonna that they wanna hear about.
I don't know, you said he's eight.
So, like, fast women, and.
Souped up cars.
You know,
you're not gonna find the right lyrics
so I would just, like, go for --
for, you know music --
Right of Spring I think would be great.
Edwin: Stravinsky Right of Spring.
Like if you've never been
to an orchestra concert,
you wanna see something,
you wanna bring your kids,
go see that piece.
It's a great starter for the twenty-first
century even though it was written --
Daniel: Stay away from things like this.
Nathaniel: Did you have a --
did you have a question?
>> Yeah. I had a question.
Umm, most of the classical music I've
heard has been background music,
umm, and I can say I like that
or I don't like that
but I get the feeling there's a whole
lot more to appreciating the structure
that goes into the music and
knowing movements versus,
uh, you know, all the different
musical forms,
how does one learn about that in order
to appreciate the music itself better?
Daniel: I don't think you have to
is how I feel but I may get some
argument with my industry members.
Nathaniel: No.
Edwin: I totally agree.
Daniel: But it's, umm,
because I listen to, uh, classical
music all the time and often
am completely ignorant of its structures
and its work so in a way that,
umm, there are people who think
that if you don't know
how a recording studio works you
can never have a true appreciation
of the White album, it's not true.
You know, but you meet
audio files all the time.
It's the production on this.
And I think, uh-uh.
Turn it off, please.
Nathaniel: If there is one thing,
I see you have a child on your lap,
it is -- it's learning music.
Umm, I mean, we treat --
my son asks me all the time,
well, how come I have to
have music lessons?
And he never comes to me and says,
how come I have to do long division?
It just doesn't occur to him.
Everyone around him has to do
long division and so does he.
And the more you, you know,
if you know the language you're gonna
respond to it that much more so.
But I don't think it should prevent
you from enjoying it at other levels.
Edwin: And I think, you know, for me when
I wanted to learn more I read liner notes.
It was very simple.
It's like there's a lot of information
out about the music
and the more you're into it just little bits --
online of course there are hundred things.
Andante.com I think has a million,
umm, composer references.
Daniel: Search on, you know, like, hotbot,
or like, those, one of the great.
Edwin: Yahoo! , Scoop,
one of the things like that.
Daniel: There's really great search engines.
Edwin: It's all out there.
Cliff: All right. And to build off that,
of course, umm,
one of the questions at the door did
mention Leonard Bernstein
did a fabulous series of recordings
introducing young people.
Edwin: On DVD.
Yeah.
They're called Young People's
Concerts with New York online.
Cliff: And then the final parting thought of
the inspiration hit me as I was sitting here
in the talk one way that the literary
world is bringing in a new audience
to the twenty-first century is a book
that just recently came out
that's called "Pride and Prejudice
and Zombies."
Edwin: And zombies.
Yeah. That's great.
Cliff: So I -- I think maybe we might --
Daniel: It would also be a
great puppet show.
Cliff: Exactly.
So we could have, like,
Claude Debussy and Zombies.
Edwin: Reader, I Ate Him.
Whatever.
Cliff: So on that note,
on behalf of the Musicians@google
and the San Francisco Symphony
we wanna thank you gentlemen
for speaking with us.
Thank you very much.
[Applause]
Thank you guys.
Daniel: You dropped your wallet.
[Applause]